[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
In diesem Video zeige ich euch wieder
drei coole Beilagen zum Grillen.
Beilagen oder je nachdem auch eine Hauptspeise.
So, wie ihr es eben anrichtet.
Zum einen gibt es gegrillte Tomaten,
ein richtig schnelles, gegrilltes Brot
und gegrillte Süßkartoffeln.
Ich starte jetzt direkt mit den gegrillten Tomaten.
Dafür verwende ich
acht Tomaten,
etwas Oregano aus meinem Garten,
eine Knoblauchzehe,
etwas Olivenöl,
Salz und Pfeffer.
Im Prinzip supereinfach.
Eigentlich ist es nicht mal so ein richtiges Rezept.
Aber ich dachte mir, komm,
wir machen das heute,
also zeige ich es euch.
Ich halbiere die Tomaten so.
So sehen sie nämlich wunderschön aus.
[Musik]
So.
So sehen sie schon mal perfekt aus.
Jetzt nehme ich das Olivenöl
und bestreiche sozusagen die Oberseite.
[Musik]
Die sind jetzt schon mal bereit.
Die rutschen so hin und her.
Okay.
Jetzt hier Oregano.
Der wird fein gehackt.
[Musik]
Das kommt jetzt hier zum restlichen Öl dazu.
Schwups!
Dann noch die Knoblauchzehe mit rein.
Hoppala!
Die braucht ihr nicht schälen,
wenn ihr eine Knoblauchpresse benutzt.
[Musik]
Da bleibt nämlich die Schale einfach über.
Und dann nur noch etwas Salz und Pfeffer rein.
Und das ist dann schon mal vorbereitet.
Womit ihr später die Tomaten
auch noch verfeinern könnt, wenn ihr wollt,
ist etwas Parmesan.
Schmeckt mit Sicherheit auch sehr, sehr, sehr lecker dazu.
Jetzt habe ich hier sozusagen noch das Öl,
was später drauf kommt.
Und die Tomaten sind jetzt bereit zum Grillen.
Aber ich bereite jetzt
erst mal noch mein Brot zu.
Geht nämlich alles superschnell.
Jetzt gibt es noch das Blitzbrot.
Und ich mache normalerweise echt supergerne
magisches Baguette zum Grillen.
Aber Blitzbrot ist super!
Denn ihr müsst es nicht aufgehen lassen,
da keine Hefe verwendet wird.
Dafür verwende ich
400 Gramm Mehl,
einen Esslöffel Backpulver,
einen Teelöffel Salz.
Hier habe ich 350 Gramm Sahnejoghurt,
50 Gramm Olivenöl,
etwas Oregano
und noch mal Olivenöl zum Bestreichen.
Jetzt könnt ihr hier direkt Salz und Backpulver
mit dem Mehl vermischen.
Blitzbrot, weil blitzschnell.
Alle Zutaten hier rein.
Auch den Joghurt.
Zack!
Das Olivenöl.
Und dann direkt verkneten.
Und ich nehme dann, wie gesagt, einfach noch Oregano dazu.
Ihr könnt aber auch Rosmarin nehmen
oder ein bisschen Pfeffer noch dazu geben
oder einfach komplett pur ohne Kräuter lassen.
Das ist im Prinzip wie so eine Art
Quark-Öl-Teig nur nicht mit Quark, sondern mit Sahnejoghurt.
[Musik]
Jetzt ist der Teig perfekt.
Und ihr habt jetzt gesehen,
die KitchenAid, die wackelt ab und zu.
Guckt mal.
Gerade bei Hefeteig.
Und ich kriege da oft viele Nachfragen,
ob das normal ist.
Ja, es ist normal.
Die gibt im Prinzip nach.
Man muss es sich so vorstellen,
wenn sie die ganze Zeit so stur stehen würde
und du hast so einen festen Teig unten drin,
gerade Nudelteig zum Beispiel,
würde die irgendwann heiß laufen.
Und die gibt einfach nach
und federt das Ganze so ein bisschen ab,
so die Bewegung, die sie macht.
Und deswegen also alles völlig normal.
Guckt mal.
Innerhalb von
einer Minute, zwei Minuten
habt ihr euren Teig fertig.
Den gebe ich jetzt hier auf eine bemehlte Unterlage.
Der ist auch echt ganz geschmeidig.
Und jetzt kommt es darauf an,
wie groß ihr die Brote haben wollt.
Ich werde jetzt
– wie viele mache ich daraus? –
acht,
acht Brote machen.
Also
halbieren,
vierteln
und dann praktisch noch mal halbieren.
Und dann habt ihr schöne Achtel.
[Musik]
Und die kurz zu Kugeln formen.
Die müssen jetzt auch nicht gleichmäßig sein.
So Brot, finde ich, darf schon selbst gemacht aussehen.
[Musik]
Und jetzt hier mit etwas Mehl
schön dünn ausrollen zu dünnen Fladen.
Entweder länglich oder rund
oder egal, welche Form auch immer.
[Musik]
Ich muss halt echt sagen, gerade so beim Grillen
finde ich es echt immer superschön,
wenn man alles selber macht.
Und, wenn man jetzt bedenkt,
dass so ein Brot, auch ein Baguette,
echt supereinfach geht,
also ich finde, da kann man sich schon die Mühe machen.
Es lohnt sich auf jeden Fall!
Und ich finde, selbst gemacht
schmeckt es halt einfach doch am besten.
Jetzt nehme ich einfach das Olivenöl.
Gut, ich habe jetzt den Pinsel der Tomaten.
Ist aber nicht schlimm.
Mein Papa würde jetzt sagen: "Es geht alles
an den gleichen Ort."
Alles in den Bauch.
Jetzt einfach von beiden Seiten mit Öl bestreichen.
Und im Prinzip ist es so eine Art Pfannenbrot.
Also ihr könnt es jetzt theoretisch
auch in einer beschichteten Pfanne anbraten
oder, wie gesagt, auf dem Grill.
Und beim Grill da brate ich es dann
nicht direkt auf dem Grillrost an,
sondern ich nehme ein Grillplatte zum Beispiel dafür,
also einfach eine Unterlage,
dass das Brot schön flach aufliegt.
Ja.
Und dann wird es von beiden Seiten
so ungefähr zwei, drei Minuten angebraten.
Das war es dann.
[Musik]
Also eigentlich müsste es jetzt reichen,
wenn ich immer die Oberseite bestreiche
und dann das nächste auflege.
[Musik]
Jetzt kommt das dritte Grillrezept,
nämlich gegrillte Süßkartoffeln.
Dafür verwende ich
ein Kilo Süßkartoffeln,
– die sind auch bereits gewaschen –
eine Zitrone oder zwei Limetten,
eine Orange,
etwas Harissa,
– das ist so eine scharfe Paste –
Olivenöl,
Salz und Pfeffer.
Jetzt nehmt ihr die Süßkartoffel
und halbiert sie der Länge nach.
Ich muss sagen, ich bin der Megasüßkartoffelfan,
Murat ja nicht so,
wie ihr vielleicht wisst.
Ei, ei, ei!
Die sind immer so hart.
Also da müsst ihr echt beim Halbieren aufpassen,
dass euch das Messer nicht abrutscht.
Am besten so einritzen und dann
zack!
Und, wenn ihr möchtet, könnt ihr jetzt
mit einem kleinen Messer bitte
hier so eine Art Rautenmuster einritzen.
Zum einen, weil es schön ist,
und zum anderen läuft dann da später die Marinade rein.
[Musik]
Die kommen jetzt bei uns auch direkt als Erstes auf den Grill.
Denn die Süßkartoffeln brauchen am längsten.
Also gehen wir kurz raus.
Der Grill ist schon heiß!
Also jetzt am besten so ein bisschen indirekt grillen,
das heißt nicht komplett über die heiße Glut.
[Musik]
Und je nach Größe der Süßkartoffel braucht sie jetzt
so etwa 25 bis 30 Minuten.
Immer mal wenden.
Auch mal schauen, dass die Schale außen nicht verbrennt.
Und solange kann ich die Marinade schon mal machen.
Also hierfür die Zitrone auspressen.
Die Orange auch auspressen.
Und, wenn ihr keine frische Orange habt,
einfach Orangensaft benutzen.
Ich schneide immer oben so den Zipfel weg.
Dann kann man die Zitrusfrüchte nämlich besser auspressen.
Ich glaube, Limette wäre schon noch mal besser gewesen.
Vor allem hätte ich dann etwas Limettenschale noch mit rein
und eben den Saft.
Ich glaube, ich schreibe es euch auch so in den Blog rein.
[Musik]
Jetzt Harissa mit rein,
zwei Teelöffel.
Die ist je nach Hersteller mal schärfer, mal weniger scharf.
Olivenöl.
Und Salz, Pfeffer.
[Musik]
Und verrühren.
Die Süßkartoffeln sind fertig.
Die Marinade, dachte ich, mache ich einfach
so ein bisschen warm, lasse sie kurz aufkochen.
So
ist die jetzt auch nicht so kalt.
Und jetzt nehmt ihr die Süßkartoffeln
und taucht sie praktisch mit der Oberseite ein
und legt sie dann hier ab.
Dann kann die Marinade schön einziehen.
Und die restliche Marinade verteile ich darüber
und kann jetzt gleich noch
die Tomaten und das Brot fertigstellen.
Und dann habe ich alle drei Beilagen fertig.
Und die Schale außen, die darf ruhig dunkel werden.
Die essen wir sowieso nicht mit.
Das könnt ihr dann praktisch
so rauslöffeln aus der Süßkartoffel.
[Musik]
Die Tomaten lege jetzt mit der Schnittfläche auf den Grill
und lasse sie jetzt hier
für etwa vier bis fünf Minuten schön grillen.
[Musik]
[Brutzeln]
Hier haben wir jetzt die Tomaten.
Ach, die sehen perfekt aus!
Und die drehe ich jetzt nur um.
Die habe ich jetzt praktisch nur auf der Schnittkante gegrillt,
drehe sie um, bestreiche sie mit der Marinade
und dann könnt ihr die warm oder auch kalt servieren.
[Musik]
Ich finde sie so besonders,
weil sie eben noch nicht so komplett gar sind,
das heißt unten so ein bisschen bissfest
und oben aber schön gar.
Mmh!
Ich gebe die Marinade drauf.
Ich erinnere mich nicht mehr,
aber ich glaube, ich habe Knoblauch drin.
Ich rieche es.
[Musik]
Jetzt kann ich die Brote grillen.
Und ihr braucht jetzt, wie gesagt, eine flache Unterlage.
Ich nehme jetzt hier einfach Gusseisengeschirr,
weil ich es halt auf dem Grill eben benutzen kann.
Entweder nehmt ihr so eine große Gusseisenpfanne
oder kleine Töpfchen,
also kleine Pfännchen.
Die sind auch süß.
Da lege ich sie jetzt rein
und grille sie dann von beiden Seiten für etwa
ein bis zwei Minuten, drei, vier.
Ha, ich hätte es vielleicht ein bisschen kleiner lassen sollen.
Denn sie sind jetzt doch
recht unförmig.
Guck dir mein Brot an!
O mein Gott!
>> SARAH: Hätte ich nicht besser hinbekommen.
>> SALLY: Aber, Entschuldigung,
ich wollte, dass es handmade aussieht.
Komm, jetzt lege ich es
noch schön ins Gusseisenpfännchen rein.
Also ein bisschen kleiner müsst ihr sie ausrollen.
Oh!
Ist das nicht süß!
Ja, das wird.
Okay!
Ihr müsst sie kleiner ausrollen.
Kleiner und dicker. Dann sind sie handlicher.
Ich habe vorhin zum Glück erwähnt,
sie sollen handmade aussehen.
Oh, ist das schön!
Also ich habe noch nie ein schöneres Brot gesehen!
Aber ich finde das schön.
Es hat eine Struktur.
Ja, es hat Struktur, dieses Brot.
Weil, ich meine, rund kann jeder.
[Musik]
Schaut mal her, wie schön das aussieht!
Ich habe jetzt hier meine drei Grillrezepte.
Also ich persönlich muss sagen,
dass ich die drei so als Hauptspeise essen würde.
Ich brauche da kein Fleisch dazu.
Wenn ihr aber Fleischliebhaber seid,
dann sind das vielleicht drei tolle Beilagen,
die ihr zu eurem Fleisch servieren könnt.
Supereinfach in der Herstellung,
supereinfach vorzubereiten
und vor allem superlecker!
Hier meine gegrillten Tomaten,
das Brot
und hier noch die Süßkartoffeln.
Was ich zum Brot dazusagen muss,
ich habe es jetzt eine Weile warm gehalten im Backofen,
weil ich einfach
– wir fotografieren ja jeden Schritt und so weiter.
Und ich würde sagen, das Brot wirklich zum Schluss
so kurz vor dem Verzehr einfach kurz grillen,
vielleicht mit der Restwärme sogar,
und dann sofort aufessen.
Perfekt!
Also probiert die Rezepte gerne aus.
Ich habe sie euch alle einzeln angelegt in meiner App.
Da findet ihr alle Rezepte kostenlos,
könnt sie hoch- und runterrechnen
oder wie immer auf sallys-blog.de.
Also viel Spaß beim Nachmachen!
Einen guten Appetit!
Und bis zum nächsten Mal!
Tschüssi!
[Musik]